a long time ago I was a professional
animator
[Music]
and during at night I would make my own
experimental films and I was spending a
lot of time way too much time in front
of the screen for work that we would be
presented on the screen I had this great
need to get my fans back on the world
you go now before the Simpsons before
Gumby before Betty Boop
before there was such a thing as cinema
and television animation was hugely
popular in this form this is a zoetrope
and you spin this drum and he looked
through the slits into the inside of the
drum and you see the animation popped to
life this is animation in physical form
and it's animation I could get my hands
on again I took these ideas to Denmark I
went there with my family on a Fulbright
fellowship it's my daughter Mia and I
rode around the city on my bicycle and
shot all the interesting moving elements
of Copenhagen the boaters in the canals
the colors that explode in spring the
free news city bikes love textures the
healthy cuisine and I brought all that
video back into the physical world by
printing it out on these long strips of
inkjet paper and cutting out the forms
now I invented my own form of the
zoetrope which remove the drum and
replaced the slits with a video camera
and this was very exciting for me
because it meant that I could make these
physical objects and I could make films
from those objects
that's me riding on my bicycle
I made about 25 paper sculptures each
the size of a bicycle wheel and I
brought them into the studio spun them
and shot them to make the film
Copenhagen cycles
[Music]
now this project not only allowed me to
get my hands back on the work again but
it helped me get my life back instead of
spending 1215 hours a day with my face
plastered to a screen I was having these
little adventures with our new family
and shooting video along the way and it
was kind of a symbiosis of art and life
and I think that it's no mistake that
zoetrope translates into the Wheel of
Life but film and video does flatten
sculpture so I tried to imagine a way
that animated sculpture could be
experienced as such and also a
completely immersive kind of animated
sculpture and that's where I came up
with the idea for the zoetrope tunnel
you walk through with a handheld strobe
and wherever you point the flashlight
the animation pops to life I plan to
finish this project in the next 30 to 40
years but I did build a half skill
prototype it's covered in velcro and I
could lay inside on this bridge and
stick animated sequences to the walls
and test stuff out people would comment
that it reminded them of an MRI and that
that medical connection spoke to me
because at the age of 14 I was diagnosed
with a degenerative retinal condition
that's slowly taking my vision away and
I never responded to that in my work so
I responded to in this piece called
implant
it is an imaginary super magnified
medical device that fits around the
optic nerve and the public is in the
sense miniaturised to experience it
[Music]
with a handheld strobe that can explore
the sculpture and discover thousands of
cell size robots hard at work leaping in
and out of the optic nerve being
deployed to the retina to repair it's my
science fiction/fantasy cure for my own
incurable disorder now in the real world
gene therapy and cheap therapy research
healthy genes are being administered to
unhealthy cells using viruses there's a
lot of colorful fluffy hope in this and
there's also some creepy threatening
idea viruses maybe becoming an invasive
species in your body
[Music]
now vision losses helped to take me away
from the things that disconnect me from
the world instead of being sealed off in
an automobile I ride my bike take buses
and trains and walk a lot and instead of
a visually intensive process in the
studio primarily I am also getting
outdoors a lot more and using more of my
senses this landscape is a couple hours
east of San Diego California my brother
lives out that way he and I went camping
there for four days and I grabbed my
camera and I walked through the canyons
and I tried to imagine and figure out
what kind of motion would be present in
this place that was so still and so
devoid of motion I think it's the
stillest place I've ever been and I
realized that it was the movement of my
own body through the landscape that was
creating the animation it was the motion
of changing perspective so I created
this piece called mud caves from those
photographs it's a multi-layered
print piece and you can think of it as a
zoetrope laid flat it's kind of my
western landscape panorama and next to
the print piece there's a video monitor
that shows the animation hidden within
the artwork I think one of the best
parts about this project for me was that
I got to hang out with my brother a lot
who lives 2,500 miles away from me and
we would just sit in this seemingly
eternal landscape sculpted by water over
millions of years and talk we talked
about our kids growing up and the
slowing pace of our parents and our dad
who's suffering from leukemia memory
loss and infection and it struck me that
as individuals were finite but as a
family we are an ongoing cycle a kind of
Wheel of Life now I want to leave you
with a tribute to one of my mentors she
reminds me that
physical presence is important and that
play is not a luxury but a necessity
she's pixie and she's our family dog and
she loves to jump and this is a new kind
of zoetrope that i developed at the
Imaging Research Center in DC in
Baltimore and I call it the real Times
okay thank you
[Applause]